for now what you need to know on a
typical
monday and by typical i mean a busy
monday a lot going on in the national
football league and the top story even
though
he's not
the guy that he once was from a sizzle
standpoint from a production standpoint
he was having his worst season before
sunday it's still a big deal when any
star player current or former or a
little bit
you know i'm trying to be nice to the
guy but he's not
can we stipulate obj isn't what he wants
was but still yeah an acl out for the
year jarring
affects cleveland in ways that we don't
yet know but still it's a big deal and i
feel bad for the guy because
he injured himself hustling
after an interception how many times do
we see guys make business decisions and
now we know why they do because you get
yourself into an uncharacteristic
situation like that and you can get
jumbled up and you can get injured and
your season can be over
yeah kudos to odell beckham for trying
to make the play you know we saw d.k
metcalf in the game last night run down
buddha baker i mean you know you like
guys to hustle in in those situations
despite uh the play not going their way
and and he was trying to make a play and
totally unfortunate i did find it sort
of funny that people said
on the internet have said all day hey
who are the browns going to go out and
trade fort receiver do they really need
another receiver i'm just saying this
this is a team that's built around the
run and chubb's going to come back and
and this to me
perhaps makes their def their offense
better because they won't have to worry
about getting the ball to odell beckham
and they can get it to the open receiver
and they can't concentrate on running
the ball all those things that they're
good at so
i want to see this offense without him
in it just to see if they're not going
to try to force the ball into odell
beckham just to keep him happy he did
lead the team in targets and maybe he
shouldn't have he hasn't been the same
receiver mike since those first three
seasons the last four seasons have not
been good he hasn't made a pro bowl and
he hasn't made a pro bowl for a reason
and as we know everyone makes the pro
bowl
well that's true we could make the pro
bowl that's how far down they are
getting in the barrel that we almost are
eligible for it all right before i echo
your thoughts because i agree with most
of what you said let's hear from kevin
stefanski the head coach of the
cleveland browns on the impact of odell
beckham jr's season-ending injury on the
team
the energy he brings to practice the
energy he brings the games uh you can't
you know you can't uh
no one else is able to bring that type
of juice
but
it's it's our job to find the guys that
that can go compete that we can go put
them in spots where they can succeed
and i think we'll be able to do that
that's not easy i don't want to have to
do it
and i'm very disappointed for odell
but that's the nature of this beast and
injuries are part of this game and
doesn't mean any of us have to like it
but we do have to deal with it
he definitely brings a lot of juice but
you know he only had one really
significant and impactful game this year
and it was against the cowboys and in
hindsight
the win over the cowboys not as
impressive as it was at the time that it
happened because the cowboys have been
anything but impressive this year since
then and i talked to stevansky right
after that game
he said it's on me to get odell beckham
jr involved early in games and then the
next week against the colts
he was
mostly a decoy
and then the next week against the
steelers he didn't do much of anything
now they went to him right out of the
gates one of the first plays from
scrimmage interception and that's what
resulted in the torn acl so they're
trying to get him the ball but it's that
pressure that constant presence that
constant thou shalt get the ball to
odell beckham jr that became distraction
for this offense over the last two years
so here's where i'm with you shireen
i don't know that this is going to make
the browns offense in the grand scheme
of things dramatically worse now it's
always helpful to have a guy who
commands double coverage a guy who runs
down the field and takes a safety with
him and opens up everything underneath i
don't know that they need that with the
running game that they have and when you
balance out the trade-off
you give up the guy who commands double
coverage
you take away the guy who demands the
ball and there's always that narrative
and there's always that pressure and it
reminds me of the year after calvin
johnson retired from the lions i
actually thought matthew stafford was a
better quarterback at least in that
first year because he could just throw
the ball to whoever was open without
holding a little bit longer to wait for
calvin johnson to get open without that
extra half second up should i throw it
even though he's double covered and
maybe he'll catch it anyway sure what
the hell i think that you removed that
look how well baker mayfield played
yesterday it's like oh he's not going to
play well without otto beckham jr well
once he got the 0 for 5 out of his
system he went 22 for 23. so i don't
think this is going to be a huge loss if
at all and i hate to say that because he
is a great player but just all the
dynamics that went along with it i don't
know that this is a major negative for
the cleveland browns
you know what for certain it takes away
mike over the next week it takes away
trade speculation and you were one who
was saying i think the browns need to
trade odell beckham well they can't do
that now that's done that's over we're
not going to be talking about that all
week and maybe that would have been
something that browns would have looked
at maybe he wouldn't have been there for
the rest of the season anyway they could
have gotten probably great value for
odell beckham and now he's not going to
be in the lineup for a different reason
and i know they don't like losing him to
injury he is a great player he does
command that respect
but i don't know that this is going to
affect their offense all that much i
think it allows them to run the ball
which is what they're really good at and
which is what they should be doing all
the time because they're really a great
run offense and take the ball out of
baker's hands don't let him make those
mistakes throw it when you have to throw
it and that's when he's that's when he's
good and that's when this offense is
good
hey throw it to donovan people's jones
right there's other guys next man up
people's jones makes the game-winning
touchdown catch yesterday jarvis landry
is still there and you don't have to go
out and make a trade to replace an odo
beckham jr just go forward with who you
have keep working the guys you have you
know they may not be trading david and
joku he's still around they got a couple
of touchdowns out of harrison bryant
yesterday they've got austin hooper so
you've got weapons use the weapons you
have and move forward and let baker
mayfield develop into the quarterback
you want to be i remember from the
moment that they traded for obj i
thought is cleveland big enough for both
baker mayfield and odell beckham jr and
i still believe the two of them never
really clicked the way that they should
have for good reason otto beckham jr
shows up for the first day of the
offseason program in 2019 poses for the
pictures speaks to the media and then
never comes back
for the voluntary portions for most of
the voluntary portions of the off-season
program while baker mayfield's there
busting his butt getting ready for the
season i think that may happen i don't
know this but i'm just applying logic
and common sense and trying to observe
and understand human nature i can't
imagine the quarterback of the team is
all that happy with the guy who does a
drive-by and as big of a star if not
bigger than baker mayfield right out of
the gate so i think this actually could
help the browns and when you look at
their schedule and i know this would
qualify me for a bingo square on the
morning show because apparently whenever
we bring up the schedule it's uh i don't
know i guess it's an objectionable thing
to actually look at the broader
perspective of the season but
the the browns have the raiders up next
and then a bye
they've got at least five more wins
on this slate of games they'll have five
more games they should win and they win
the games they should win now yesterday
it took a little extra work and it
looked like it wasn't going to happen
but they still got the win and that's
going to give them confidence going into
this game at home against the raiders
after the buy texans win
eagles should be a win but with the
eagles you never know at the jaguars hey
hey that's just chalk that up as a w at
the titans and the ravens are two games
that they need to worry about and they
got the steelers week 17 after they play
the the two new york teams there's three
games that they should lose
three games titans ravens steelers the
others could should win the raiders i
think is the one that falls into the
middle ground this week especially with
the raiders trying to get back on the
right path after getting blown out
yesterday so i think the brown's got 10
maybe 11 wins that'll get into the
playoffs and they're gonna and and you
know what's going to happen
as soon as the season ends
the narrative is going to be they they
should just go ahead and trade although
beckham jr now they don't they don't
need him the team got better once he got
injured that's what's going to happen if
this team makes it to the playoffs as it
should
yeah and kevin stefanski we're going to
be talking about him as coach of the
year because it's going to be oh look
what he did without odell beckham you
know disregarding what that schedule
looks like and they probably would have
won these games either way anyway
but he is going to be a candidate for
coach of the year considering the browns
history there's no doubt about that if
they go do what we think they should do
what the expectations are what the
lion's gonna say as they go play all
these games but i would like to know
mike from your perspective because you
have pushed him you have pushed a trade
thinking that they should trade him what
does this do for his trade value do you
think in the off season is there going
to be a team that would step up after
this injury to say yeah we want odell
beckham on our team and we're willing to
give you a high price for him
it's going to be hard to trade him now
until you know that he's healthy and
when we know that he's healthy
april may
june yeah so i i think that
no one's going to touch him until they
know that he's healthy and even then i
think the value has gone down
dramatically
they
they could have traded him this past off
season and there was a report from wfan
that the vikings and the browns were
talking about it and of course everybody
denied it because that's what you have
to do doesn't mean it didn't happen
and and i wouldn't have been surprised
if something would have bubbled up this
week maybe from his perspective not the
browns saying let's cut and run
but maybe some agitation from odell
beckham jr if he had mustered the nerve
to say i want out i i think he always
wants to be perceived as a great
teammate and great teammates don't say
trade me off of this team
but my guess is he would have welcomed
it if the opportunity would have arisen
to go to a better team to to go to a
team that can beat good teams that was
part of his complaint last week in his
press conference when he explained why
he was frustrated they're beating bad
teams they're not beating good teams
give us all these bad teams that's fine
all that gets this is a first round exit
from the playoffs so
i think that
there's an alternate universe out there
where he didn't get injured yesterday
and this week speculation reports rumors
and the possibility of a deal being done
for odell beckham jr
wednesday or thursday and remember those
are the days to keep an eye on wednesday
or thursday of this week because of the
covet 19 delay you've got to do the five
days of testing before you can get into
the team if you want your guy that you
trade for ready for week nine you got to
get the deal done by the end of this
week so he can join you for practice
next week
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports